[Musique]
bonjour à tous et moi cloud ouais ça
vous le saviez déjà
et j'ai quelques conseils pour vous
aider à traverser cette période
difficile
premièrement respecter les règles de
distanciation physique je m'excuse j'ai
pas vu que tu es là et je le fais depuis
toujours là en plus il ya plein de
choses que vous pouvez faire à la maison
comme fait de l'exercice en dansant
comme un pro et innover en essayant de
nouvelles recettes
j'adore le savant mélange de nounours
gélatine et de viande
vous pouvez faire des appels vidéos pour
tous vos rendez vous importants droit ou
juste vous amuser ok pas trop non plus
ça ne vient pas naturellement mais
essayer d'être gentil avec les autres
c'est un moment difficile pour tout le
monde
ben voilà enfin prenez soin de vous et
souvenez-vous que nous vivons cette
situation ensemble ensemble mais
séparément ouvriers ce que je dis pas
renié
[Musique]